la planète hip hop est en pleine
mutation ou quand le breaker devient
dans ce milieu des années 90 la
breakdance devient une discipline
artistique à part entière
dix ans seulement après avoir débarqué
des états unis avec le graffiti le
deejaying et le rat les piliers de la
culture hip hop dans les années 80 le
break séduisait les jeunes des banlieues
françaises et se pratique est dans la
rue entre les vagues les coupoles et
autres toupie sur la tête ses danseurs
amateurs développe une technique inédite
conscient de ce potentiel certain
breaker avait déjà d'autres ambitions
notre armée va pas rester éternellement
dans la rue c'est sûr que des bus aux
prémices de ce mouvement il était
développé principalement dans la rue que
ce soit pour la danse le chant ou de la
peinture mais maintenant c'est juste
qu'ils soient dans des places comme la
grande halle de la villette pour
d'autres places en europe
très vite les breakeurs investissent les
salles de spectacles et théâtre et même
les opéras c'est la rencontre du
breakdance et de la danse classique
[Musique]
on s'est aperçu que ça colle de suite tu
la mets sur la tête est relativement sur
la tête permet sur les points clés mais
l'un derrière l'autre ça crée une image
nouvelle c'est vraiment la fusion de
deux styles et ensemble nous font plus
qu'un je pense que c'est un bon message
aux artistes mais également sportifs les
breakeurs se distingue aussi lors de
compétitions nationales et
internationales
depuis plusieurs années les battent
elles se multiplient et représentent
parfois un véritable tremplin pour les
danseurs il ya énormément de gens qui on
gagne le beauty comme on dit donc battle
of the year se retrouvant des compagnies
de danse contemporaine c'est vraiment un
ça peut être un marchepied vers autre
chose et vers la professionnalisation de
la rue aux planches de l'opéra en
passant par les compétitions sportives
en trente ans la breakdance est imposée
comme une discipline incontestable
au point aujourd'hui d'être envisagée
comme un sport olympique
[Applaudissements]